Yeah. Welcome back. The screen is bright. Rawkode
Academy shining light. Another Monday,
live and loud. Joining the cloud native crowd.
Got a new tool on the scene today.
Up bright.
So grab your coffee, settle down. Best tech
stream in the whole town. Rawkode live is
on the air with card knowledge we can
share. Let's get it started. Feel the buzz.
Yeah. Card and K, it's because.
There's just because it speeds up the oh,
here we go.
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is Rawkode Live, and I am your
host, David Flanagan, also known across the Internet
as Rawkode.
And that was the most awkward two minutes
and fifty seconds of my life because for
some weird reason, I could not hear the
music and just had to wait patiently for
the stinger.
Fortunately, I have two fantastic guests joining me
today who kinda filled me in as we
went.
Rawkode Live is all about taking a look
at cloud native technology to make your Kubernetes
and cloud native lives a little bit easier.
And today, we're taking a look at a
project from the team
called and
guiding us on our journey today.
Two fantastic guests. Hello, Martin, and hello,
How are you? Good.
Very good. You know, just let's assume
the audience
hasn't met you before. Can you please take
a minute? We'll start with you, Martin, and
then move down away just to say hello
and share anything else you wish to share
before we kick off this great session.
Sure.
Big fan. I've watched
quite a few of
the episodes.
Talk about that later.
Martin Sadler, I do a lot of things
with products now over at Morentis.
Before that, I was at Weaveworks where we
played with something called GitOps and then helped
Stefan and team
get Flex up and running over ControlPlaying
before hopping over here to Marentis.
Awesome. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah. I've watched a
lot of, Rawkode Academy stuff.
I mean, I've known David for I think
five years now since I joined the community.
I was working at Harness be before that,
data kiosk data on the Litmus Kiosk project,
which hopefully graduates soon. But then post that
last year, I joined Randy
and the OSPO team at Mirantes,
Martin, everyone.
And right now, I'm closely working with the
and communities.
And, again, love what Rawkode has been doing
for the community.
Yeah. Well, you're both far too kind, but
I really appreciate that. Thank you so much.
And I appreciate you both taking time out
of your day to sit down and help
show me and the audience some awesome technology.
So we've now said Cordon three times, which
means that in Candyman style, it should jump
through the mirror and say hello to the
audience. But before they do that, they should
know what they're getting involved with today. Can
one of you or both of you just
take a minute to explain what the Cordon
project is and the problem that it solves?
Sure.
I'll take a stab at this one.
What Cordon is, it is a
thinking about
cloud native over the last ten years where
we've grown,
complexity has
continued to just get more and more complex.
Right? We all know this. There's lots of
tools.
More tools are coming as CNCF
grows
at a steady state,
And that's very good. The challenge comes in
when you try to then glue those things
together.
So the concept of Cordant,
it's a play on
Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy. So it started off
as
something called Project 2A.
2A
is hexadecimal
four forty two.
So people were having a a bit of
a good time. But we were very serious
about what it was that we wanted to
do.
How do we make
Kubernetes
flexible,
simple,
still able to do all the complexities that
you wanna do.
And that's what we're doing.
Sure. That's usually with Kubernetes, it's name those
three things and then pick half of one.
Are you saying that's not the case today?
I don't know. I I think there's a
lot of lessons learned that we've been able
to apply. I'm I'm pretty chuffed with
where the project is right now. I'm I'm
pretty happy
with doing it. I think
we brought in
a pretty pretty good team of
you know, I've got all the the wars,
the scars, more wounds from from
Weaveworks with Weave GitOps Enterprise, with Weave Cloud,
and we have the same thing for MKE,
you know, the Marantis Kubernetes Engine,
Harness, as you know. So
lots of experience and and trying to think
about if we had to do this over
again, how would we do it? And
this is
our our view of what that looks like
for Kubernetes.
Okay.
So, obviously, the name has that k zero,
Arden, and and there's another moment as open
source project called k zeros. How do these
two
correlate, work together, compete against each other? How
how what's the landscape look like from the
moment as stack? Oh, yeah. Sure. So moment
as, you know, initially started off with OpenStack.
And then, you know, as we started getting
into
cloud native,
we
started creating products initially around
MCC
seven years ago, I believe, maybe eight at
this point in time.
You know, we did absorb some of Docker.
So we we did that. So we we
had,
a platform based around Swarm. So that's MKE
three today. So it's we still provide it.
It's still in demand.
The next release of MKE is MKE four,
and that one is is Kubernetes based.
But it is it is a different
product set trying to do different things.
And then we also have,
k z r s.
I'll talk about that a little bit more
in-depth because it is really a core component
of
Cordant.
Our we have another product called MSR, and
that's Harbor.
And we we, you know, do a lot
of upstream work there. So
pretty broad,
grouping of products.
What
Cordon is trying to do
is
create a template by design.
Right? So take everything that we do, and
the inspiration is not something that we invented.
Inspiration comes from
really smart things everybody did before. So for
example,
Cluster API, foundational for us doing that.
We looked at different projects around services
and how do you capture Kubernetes state.
And that's
why we looked at Svelteus and said, This
is a good way for us to start
the project.
And then with observability,
it's really selecting some of the pieces that
are working really well in the community. So
Victoria Metrics,
as an example.
Open cost is another one. And then being
able to put this together
into three components:
Kubernetes Cluster Manager,
Kubernetes State Management, and then Kubernetes
Observability and FinOps.
So those are the three pillars.
And it's all template based. So instead of,
for your cluster deployments,
you would
typically have, what, six, seven YAML files that
you probably have to edit and work on.
We take that, create a template of it,
and now it's one YAML file.
Well,
it's it's one YAML file, but it is
still
compliant.
It still, you know, follows the APIs,
is well understood.
There's not a new language to learn,
and and you can and you can go
with it.
I'll I'll show some diagrams here in a
second. But we're trying to apply that theory
across the board.
And the foundation of that today is K0S,
so our Kubernetes distribution,
our open source distribution.
It's formally just gone into the CNCF.
We're really happy about that.
And and then we've built on top of
that. So Cosmetron
being able to bootstrap
and then build up from there.
Alright.
Yeah. A lot of moving parts,
but hopefully a lot of complexity
wrangled.
I mean, you mentioned the your Mirantis engine
v three, which was Docker Swarm based. And
Mhmm. I think back to you know, I
don't even know when it was. Let's say
ten years, nine years, something like that.
Swarm was simple, and it worked.
And I'm not saying Kubernetes is crap because,
you know, it's been a big part of
my career for the last ten years. But
at the same time,
it's a completely different path and not the
one I wanted to take back when I
started doing all this stuff. Now yous have
both been in this space a long time
too. Like, how how did we end up
here with this? Everything's configurable. Everything's
you go template nested in a YAML.
I don't wanna say a bad word. Right?
But it's it's not easy. The complexity of
cloud native is probably at the highest it's
ever been. And you mentioned the landscape and
you said it's growing at a steady rate.
I mean Yeah. I think it's worth. I
think it's exponential. I mean, every time you
look at that landscape, it's, you know, it's
just going bigger and bigger and bigger to
the point where the jokes aren't even funny
anymore because we can't print it out anymore
to make the joke. It's too big. So
Yeah. Yeah. I I'm just curious. Like, it's
always important to take a look at projects
that are trying to
manage the complexity and provide abstractions, opinions, and
make it easier. Right? And I'm hoping that
that's what we're gonna see today. But I'm
just curious on,
you know, two people that have been in
this industry a while, especially in this space.
Like, how did we get here versus what
was the simple path? I sort of get
it myself.
I mean, I I think part of it
is that Kubernetes is a project of projects
in a way,
really,
and it's a welcoming community too.
We could have been very, very strict in
one
function
is only handled by one
of the projects, right? So you'd have Flux
or Argo. You would have
you know, it's the the the point is
that we welcomed in so many,
and we've created all this complexity
because of it. Right?
And I think that's
that's the biggest challenge.
I I would actually blame sidecars for a
lot of this.
But
we make it incredibly easy for anybody to
develop
something
and get it
functioning and working in Kubernetes, and then
getting it
into incubation,
getting it sandboxed,
all of that.
So I
think complexity is actually a benefit.
It's diversity,
but it's gotten very, very complex.
You're right. I I think that was a
great line. I'm gonna steal that one, actually.
I'm I'll rephrase it slightly, but, you know,
what was it you said? Complexity
is is choice.
You know, we have the freedom to swap
out any single component of a Kubernetes cluster
that we can. As you said, multiple get
out providers, multiple service mesh providers, multiple logging
and open telemetry back end, all this stuff.
We have so much choice.
But sometimes
when you're learning this stuff, you need someone's
opinions to guide you. So with that,
do you want to share some screens and
examples of what we're gonna be looking at
today with Cardan, or do you want me
to dive straight into the documentation and talk
about it as we go? What's your preference?
No. Let me let me actually share Yeah.
Of course, man.
An overview.
Nothing ready here.
Where did
I can find my
slides.
Think as Martin finds out his
I mean, shares his screen and shares his
slides, I would like to add something to
what we were discussing about the landscape and
how complex it has become.
I think,
to be honest, the community or we as
as a whole, as an entity is to
be blamed to make the landscape more complex
because, you know, a lot of things that
Kubernetes
helped resolve and provided
in itself created those complexities.
And I believe as a community, we were
not able to resolve it or because we
were so conflicted, we moved on to make
so many more projects.
And every aspect or every
problem that Kubernetes threw
to the community, it had to become a
separate project. That is how
the whole landscape of the business has grown
and everyone has come up with their own
project. And as,
you know, Martin spoke of that Flux and
Orgo or maybe, you know, each and every
project is
I mean, there's different
service meshes,
policy,
resilience,
testing, incident management,
storage,
DNS.
So I I still feel that a lot
of it could have maybe become
part of the Kubernetes community itself or could
have been resolved with special interest groups.
But then, again, people focused more on expanding
the landscape.
And although as as as I agree with
David where, you know, choice
makes the community diverse
or makes it, like, better, but I I
I still feel that, you know,
it it it'll keep growing because, you know,
there are
multiple projects coming in, people separating from communities
and building their own projects, try basically trying
to create problems for Kubernetes to,
again, solve them.
That's that's how things look right now.
And that is where, you know, you'll you'll
see more things getting conceptualized
even what we are talking about, Codent as
a tool.
A lot of people are talking about platform
engineering today, which I believe existed forever, but
now it has become a niche or
in itself a concept.
So, yeah, I I personally feel that it
will keep growing and we'll see more sub
projects becoming concepts and then maybe
becoming one
added conference
or topic or colocated
event for
a KubeCon,
you could say.
Yeah. Yeah. With that, I'll I'll Yeah. You're
%
Correct. Right? I mean and this isn't even
a new problem. How many distributions of Linux
do we have? How many configuration management tools
did we have in the early two thousands?
Like,
developers just like to hack on stuff, and
then you've gotta find out which one's the
right one and which one's the wrong one.
Did
you find your slides? Yeah. I did. I'm
trying to see if I can share the
screen.
Oh, fingers crossed.
Yeah. I always
be careful about sharing. See if that does
that actually work?
Yes. I see a card and architecture overview,
not your bank details. So I'm gonna hop
over.
No. It yeah. It's not that. It's
careful keeping
your
slide decks
in the public
folders of your company because people will
modify them. So fortunately, I had an archive.
So we're fine.
I'm only gonna use this just for visual
cues.
So that's what I like to do. You
know, this is a tech
talk,
not a sales talk. But I think it's
very good to sort of try and establish
what is Cordant today. Cordant today,
it's essentially
three
pillars:
your cluster management, your service management,
and your observability.
And the way that you can think about
it is very much,
what is a cluster? That's what KCM solves,
right? So it does the provisioning.
It manages the lifecycle.
We use CAPI because we're not reinventing anything
new. We're sticking as close to open source
as possible.
It also does some of the initial integration
work.
The second one is
our state, so
coordinate
state management.
And this is what runs on the cluster.
So what's
actually running inside of it? And we have
a concept of something called VJET services.
But essentially,
is Kiverno running in it?
Is
NGINX
Ingress in it? All of these different components,
that's a responsibility
for KSM.
And then
what are my clusters? How are they performing
and how much is it costing me? That's
the third pillar.
And
those three
combined with the catalog, because everybody has a
catalog these days, pretty useful,
really forms
what Cortant is for us.
And the way that we do this is
we
just focusing in on
something like, the cluster management here,
we've
taken
the
cluster API, and we've created templates
for as many of the common
CAPI providers
that we believe
everybody wants to to have.
Cordon, again, you know, it's less than a
year old.
We have
AWS.
We've got Azure. We've got
quite a few. One of the things I
worked on very, very quickly when I got
here is to make sure that we had
SSH or something,
so we have that as well. But the
goal here is
define everything in a YAML file, which you
have here. I'm just looking at my screen
over here. And you can see
it is
production cluster template.
The environment is production.
We version it so that it's immutable,
this template, and then you would update the
version to get to the next one.
This one specifically is around AWS.
So it's AWS credentials.
You define all of the VPC,
CNI, Selium, etcetera.
And that really is
I mean, what is that? Seven YAML files
typically that you touch to be able to
do this?
So that's that's the the idea here in
that you can define these templates
and then literally swap out AWS
for Azure or for SSH or for wherever
it is
that you that you would like to use
leverage.
Fallback is SSH right now.
We've had our first open source contribution
for Hertzner, I think, for Hertzner.
But, again, if you're gonna be on something
like Scaleway, we don't have anything yet for
it,
but we do have the SSH provider
to be able to to get you moving.
Nice.
Yeah. So that's that is what we've done.
It's interesting that you mentioned Hetzner and.
Don't wanna make any assumptions to see where
you're at in London, but let's assume you
were.
I was.
A lot of the conversations that were happening
that entire week were
European
people trying to get off of US hypervisors
onto these smaller European clouds. Like, data sovereignty
was a very, very big topic.
I'm sure AWS and GCP are the one
that's talking about this, but it it was.
And a lot of people were like, I
need, you know, scale. We have an ElasticMetal
project. How do I use it with Kubernetes?
And the answer right now is the hard
way. And it's the same with Hertzner's bare
metal and OVH's bare metal and all these
other things as well. So Exactly. There there's
a big space right now for these companies
to get involved with these open source projects
that do support CAPI and make their clouds
sustainable for people adopting Kubernetes without all of
the crazy complexity.
Yeah. I I could go off on a
wild tangent on I I do sound I
do sound American, but that's only because I
lived there for twenty years.
And I've been back fifteen years and I
still haven't lost the accent. So
I thought you started English. Was like completely
wrong. Oh yeah. No, I'm English. You're
one of the first
Anyway,
no, data sovereignty is a big thing. I
think that one of the challenges that,
some of the
cloud providers in Europe have
is that maybe they lack the scale,
perceived
scale. I wouldn't say it's real.
But there's a challenge in that, well, if
I
put everything in scale way,
then how
do I set something up in The UK,
or how do I do something else?
Important is because we do this templating,
it is literally
changing one YAML file and renaming that service
template,
the cluster template,
to reflect that infrastructure provider.
Okay.
Yep.
We we've got a lot of interest. A
lot of people are asking us about how
to do this.
So service templates, same sort of thing. Again,
you know, the structure is starting to look
familiar.
Deployment methods, helm charts,
raw Kubernetes manifests,
and operator based
deployments.
So we support as many as possible.
We also have a project
called Recustomize
so that if you have
your clusters handcrafted
because of your expertise or used
something else,
it will
extract,
it will re customize your cluster,
provide that, and then you can then use
that to provision
through KSM
into your coordinate cluster. So there are ways
to be able to do it.
Again,
immutable versions
with your upgrade paths, and we'll talk a
little bit about
control and data access and things like that.
Configuration management,
templated values always,
environmental overrides,
and then
drift detection,
all of the benefits that you get from
the Svelteos project, because when we started,
we adopted Svelteus
to help us
manage
state.
That doesn't mean that
you're locked in.
And one of the reasons why
Svelteus was very appealing,
at least for me personally,
was to ensure that we did not lock
ourselves into either flux
or into Argo.
Because depending on
who you are, you might have a preference
for one or the other.
And this is sort of the one of
the core fundamentals
for Cordant
is while Svelteos
handles the management of templates
at the at the
platform engineering team level,
one of the service templates is also Flex
CD. Another of the service templates is Argo
CD.
So
your development teams, your individual clusters
can provide Flex or Argo, right?
And we're trying to approach it
across the board this way. So another example,
Kiverno
or
OPA
Gateway,
right? Gatekeeper, right? Yeah. Gatekeeper. Yeah.
Would I say gateway? K.
This is my first computer I ever had.
Yeah. Gatekeeper.
Those,
you know, we give choice.
Right?
Yeah. I think that's a very balanced approach.
I mean, my
opinion is unless they're a bit spicier. I
always say if if anyone's using Argo, they're
using the wrong tool for the wrong reason.
FluxCD just got so much right that I
think people need to pay more attention to
they go to Argo for the UI and
then don't realize how it works under the
hood is very different to FluxCD.
But that that's just my take. You know?
You get what you want people, but, yeah,
check your flux.
I think think flux is I think flux
is very, very good. I'm personally
invested in that thing. So
I I think I think we'll always have
opinions in Kubernetes, and that's what makes
Kubernetes
interesting
and actually fun to fun to be involved
in. Right?
Personal the personal opinion there. Yeah.
I think I think your audience is starting
to pick up the same
thing again here, and that is,
again, it's another template.
It does
you know, focuses in on on metrics
and logging.
Cost is
one of the more complex things, and we're
working very hard. Right now, we're working with
the
open source
you know, the open cost
project
and looking at how we actually invest a
little bit in there as well to,
help solve some of the
some of the
minutiae of of getting your billing data,
into
into the platform. I mean, you can upload
as you know, you can upload these things
with the c CSV file,
but that means that your data needs to
be correct.
And what we'd like to do is be
able to improve the already great
API support that everybody has out there,
which make it all that much better. Alright.
So you got the cluster manager, you've got
the state management, and you have
observability. And those are those are sort of
the three
the three tiers.
Nice. So I'll try and recap that in
one sentence to make sure I've not got
anything completely wildly inaccurate.
But the three components seem to be responsible
for providing a wrapper around cluster API with
some sort of opinions on how to get
a
cluster with less opinions on how to compose
that together. So the opinions are, if you
need to deploy it to GCP or AWS,
we've got a template for that, but you
still get to pack each individual component.
And then we have the service catalog, which
allows us to understand what is running in
each cluster.
And then there's the observability part saying, okay.
Are we doing this in a way that
is efficient, and are we doing this in
a way that isn't gonna bankrupt the business
in six months' time? Because you're trying to
tackle quite a lot of that life cycle
of a Kubernetes cluster,
which is a very ambitious task.
Yeah. Is that close enough to correct? That's
yeah. That's that's spot on. And I I
think already you're gonna have,
you know, some of your audience already call
out, then how do you actually control
that environment? And coordinate
coordinate
is
very much focused on
where'd he go? Very much focused on
fleets.
I hate the term fleet.
I absolutely
guessed it.
But the thing is, if you have
one Kubernetes cluster, two, three, four, you're fine.
Once you start scaling beyond that, that's when
you start having issues.
I think that
one of the reasons why we've overused
namespaces
is because
it's been so difficult and challenging to actually
run clusters
effectively,
destroy them, bring them back up. So my
preference is
lots of small clusters, not one big cluster
with a lot of namespaces in it.
And Cordant helps you able to do that
so you can do it very quickly.
We've spent a lot of time building out
our RBAC credentials.
I mean, it's all there on GitHub for
everyone to view.
But what
it allows us to do with these templates
is then we can gate these things. So
you have the concept of platform engineering,
and you have the select few in platform
engineering
who
create these templates. They'll create the cluster template.
They'll create
the service template
observability.
And then your platform
team would work with the development environment, developer
team.
And then you might only give that development
team
enough to change one or two of the
variables in your template that they can change.
And so what that means is that you
have a way to actually establish control
of your Kubernetes environment but still be able
to empower
development teams,
DevOps teams
to be able to, you know,
toggle,
you know, how many nodes are gonna be
spun up or
whatever the context is that you that you
want to be able to provide them. So
I think that is also sort of a
critical piece of Cordant
that we took a lot of time thinking
about.
Alright.
Yep.
Sweet. I think we've got enough context there
where we should get hands on, show people
how to get started, and then take a
look at some
more concrete examples as we move forward. So
I am
going to share my screen now
Okay. And go to the docs.
Alright. And I'm gonna follow along.
My docs here too.
Alright.
And
there we go. Back over here. Let's get
my screen up there.
Really need to find a way to make
this less clicky
and go.
Alright. So I've got .io.
That is k0rdnt.
K 0 r d e n t I
o.
The links, of course, will be in the
description after the fact.
We're gonna click on documentation
and quick starts, I'm assuming, or if I
gotta do something Yep. First.
Right. Let's go to let's go to quick
starts.
So we need to get an environment that
allows us to use Cardan.
We need a Kubernetes cluster for hosting Cardan
itself and a cloud environment to deploy our
workload clusters. I'm just gonna use the CAPI
terminology here. I don't know if Cardan has
something of its own. No. We use CAPI.
Absolutely right.
And then use Cardan to get that managed
cluster for us.
So
this is where I always regret my choice
of Linux distribution, but hopefully, can get through
this.
Next. I see it. I've
got a laptop with
on it.
I don't use it that much.
So
so the first step you have to do
is you if you see where it says
quick start, see first set up a management
cluster.
Yeah. So I could just use
kind for that. Right? That's what you're suggesting
here too. Perfect. Alright.
Let's do
card then. How long?
I'll run dev in it because, of course,
I don't actually have any tools installed in
this wacky box.
But, hopefully, that won't take more than a
few seconds.
I mean, there's nothing in it. I don't
know why it's taking so long.
Come on.
I should've ran this twenty minutes ago.
Alright. There we go.
And let's pop this open. So for anyone
who's not familiar, dev env is just what
is next massacre issues because we don't install
stuff.
I'm gonna remove all this stuff. We'll send
this in. That's too much.
There we go.
And I'll remove all this nonsense so that
I'm not polluting your screens with things you
don't need to pay attention to. So we
do need some packages
to have get. I also don't like that
syntax.
We want kubectl.
We want kind.
We probably need helm. I'm just gonna add
a few things. I don't know if we
need these, but put them down.
Do I need anything else beyond that? Is
there a coordinate CLI that I'm going to
need?
You you'll you'll do a curl and pull
it
down, and it'll it'll
it'll grab what you need.
And just
I I will check and see. I I'm
assuming it's not here, but you know? Yeah.
No. Okay. Maybe we'll we'll add that.
Alright. So that gives me, hopefully, the tools
that I need. Just this mean that I'm
not switching between terminals too much.
I can start to reload this.
And I have KubeControl
helm,
and I should
oh, what? I just off.
I do this every single time. It's the
wrong helm. Helm and and next is some
weird tool.
So I
do that all the time,
which means this has to be Kubernetes helm.
Like so.
So if it reloads,
it should get us the Kubernetes helm, which
is probably the only thing I don't have
cached. It's I don't ever use helm. I'm
not a big fan. But, again, that's a
space to take for another episode. It's funny.
I I'm not quite a fan either.
Kite
cluster.
Create oh, create cluster. Right? There
we go.
And, hopefully, that won't take too long. What
we can do in the interim is pop
back over here.
My cluster is spinning up.
We need k zeros.
Why do I need k zeros?
It's just to
install the the
the management cluster. There are other ways to
doing it of of using something else. Mhmm.
You don't have to, but it's just this
is the quick start. So that's why
in the documentation, we have we have it
like that. Woo hoo.
We have a next package.
Alright.
So let's add k zero CTL.
Reload.
And that should give us what we need
there. So we have a cluster. We've got
k zeros.
So I don't need to do this,
but I am gonna have to run
the k zeros install the controller.
So
I'm curious. Why
does my k zeros, which is gonna deploy
something to my Kine cluster, require a pseudo
at the start, or is that just
over permissive dot?
I think it
you need
I think it's just being slightly aggressive.
Oh, wait. Is this the new oh, that's
not an alternative to a cluster?
No?
Kind. Kind create cluster.
Yeah. I'm confused.
Because we have a get nodes.
It's our
kind cluster.
I could use case to spin up another
cluster.
I'm gonna skip it just now. We can
come back. Okay. Let's see. Let's just let's
think. Let's see maybe the docs saying you
can do one or one or the other
way
because
I don't wanna make too many assumptions. But,
yeah, I'm gonna I'm gonna skip over it.
We've got kube control.
We have a kube config. If I need
to, I can run get nodes. I'm happy.
Alright. There's Helm. I've done it. I'm not
happy, but I've done it. Now we want
to install cord into the cluster.
So
Helm install,
this is the KCM.
So it's a cluster manager
deploying from an OCI image
into a namespace within kind.
Easy.
Yeah. Here we go.
So this gives us a coordinate management
cluster where we can run and see the
pods running in that namespace.
So
give that one more minute
and then check that projects Feltos pods are
running. Nice.
So I can see here there's Cosmetron. It's
a KCM cluster manager controller. We've got the
CAPI stuff running on here.
I'm not sure what CAPI is.
CAPI. It's a it's
a a VMware Kepc's
VMware.
Right?
Not sure. And we have the flux source
controllers.
Alright.
I need faster Internet.
Come on.
That's so sure.
I don't run a Mac anymore. It's been
a long time. But I was always impressed
when home Bruce switched over to use an
OCI for all of their package deliveries. Like
I said, that was a pretty slick move
by the project.
Oh, I think it's I think it's brilliant.
We we
we're all in on OCI.
Alright.
This looks much more manageable than the docs.
You know, I'm I'm I don't have a
CAPP or a CAPP, so I was curious
to see that there. But I do see
we've got Valero, so this is the backup
stuff, the source controller and stuff. But yeah.
That looks happy. It's running. There's no crashes.
So
we want to check if we have projects
Or no.
Did I do something wrong?
I'm catching up to you. I'm I'm doing
the same thing. Alright.
And
Helm is taking forever.
Did that work?
Not skipped anything.
I wonder if it's just a
timing thing.
You you wouldn't you wouldn't see it in
you you likely will not see it in
here. We have to deploy a child cluster
for SvelteS to really kick in,
and then it'll then it'll pull it.
Alright. I'm
just waiting.
Maybe I was a bit too quick to
skip the k zeros one.
Oh, yeah. No. Okay. So it's an alternative
because under
here, it says k zeros isn't supported on
macOS. So you can use kind or you
can use k zero. Okay. So I would
try to skip that. We've got kib control.
We did tell Carden.
I do seem to have a management cluster.
Okay. We've not deployed KSM yet. So we
only deployed KCM,
which tells me maybe this this Yeah. There's
a step missing here from the documentation. So
maybe we can just work that out. I
yeah. I think you just continue on, and
it'll pull it up.
Let's
Oh, there we go. Okay. So it's working
behind the scene. Right? It's just like, it's
my slow Internet, but we do have a
project Svelteos namespace,
which has a whole bunch of con okay.
I am just being far too impatient, and
I should
take a minute.
Well, my my helm is taking I'm getting
a special word then.
You're hoping I could pay on helm from
source.
No. No. No.
No. He's
on the debug box, so it should be
super quick.
Alright.
Alright. Let's just mains is running. I'm I'm
gonna just keep popping down here. So
we should be able to run get management
and the cluster management's namespace, and it'll tell
us of our management plan is ready yet,
which ours isn't, which is fair enough because
things are still downloading behind the scenes. Yeah.
The system data is okay.
We can run,
get provider templates to see the providers that
we have,
and then we can start to put together
our first cluster template. So are those available?
They are. Right. I don't need to wait
for a healthy management cluster, which is nice.
So we can deploy to AWS, Azure, Docker,
GCP,
Cosmetron,
OpenStack, vSphere, etcetera.
Yeah. One thing to call out for everyone
here, we we are renaming it, but the
the Cosmetron is the SSH provider.
Ah, right. Nice. Okay. So it's a little
confusing.
We're we're fixing that.
Alright. Running running running running running running running
running running.
Capital was still
alright. So it's just a couple of the
provider controller managers running there. So
we are getting closer. So why don't we
start putting together a template?
So
we can also list list cluster templates.
So this is beyond the providers.
Okay. So there's AWS EKS,
standalone and hosted, GCP, GKE hosted, and standalone.
What's the difference between GCP hosted and GCP
standalone? Is that something I should be familiar
with? Well, I mean, it's it's
it's it depends on who's who's managing
those
nodes. Right? So you have the concept of
both you know, for example,
AWS,
can run Kubernetes where
you manage the
cluster controller,
the management of
that cluster, what we call child clusters.
Or you know? So if it's EKS,
then the control plane is
Amazon's EKS control plane
versus
if it's, you know, EC two, then it's
our control plane.
Right. Okay. Gotcha.
Yeah. I didn't actually notice that. It's it's
hosted CP and standalone CP. Okay. Exactly.
Alright. So now let's go for I mean,
I'm I'm tempted to be really brave in
doing your SSH one, but let's try not
to break things any any
more than I already have. Yeah. I I
like the SSH one.
I mean, it's tempting. I have a
scale way ElasticMetal machine just sitting there running
barely anything on it. It's nothing to do.
Right? Yeah. Maybe that'll be something I do
in my spare time. Let's focus on the
GCP approach.
I am logged in. I have a project.
It's my production project, so hopefully nothing too
bad goes wrong.
Do I need a service account?
Then you go to where you are.
Editor permissions.
I mean, I could do that.
Alright.
Console.
Cloud.
We're just gonna land it on my cloud
run services.
I think what I'll do is just because
it needs editor permission, let's say I'm gonna
create
a project
with a service account to minimize the blast
radius.
Yeah. You can see I'm doing a lot
of transcription stuff on these videos. In fact,
here we go. This is actually Timoney with
Stefan. I just landed on this one absolute
randomly from the logs, but there you go.
Joining us in Spirits even if not person.
So let's switch projects.
Cardents.
It also means a service account. I can
just if I flash it, it's not a
big deal, and I can kill the whole
project. So I like that.
I've I've already Yeah.
I've
already promised Stefan that we'll get to volume
into.
So Nice. Such a good project. And if
Stefan watches this at any point, I still
want that controller for Flux. Get on it,
man. Come on.
Mhmm.
Okay.
K. I am
service
accounts.
There we go.
Create new
Header current
role
currently is basic header. And there we go.
Next.
And done.
Download keys.
Where am I?
And
JSON. Alright. I have a key that should
be on my desktop.
Well no. So that's good.
What do I need to do? I need
to store this key inside of
a secret object. So I'm assuming this is
just
oh, I'm putting this into my my local
management cluster. Right. Okay.
Got it. Got it. Got it.
You're you're doing the my you're you're a
live tester for the documentations.
So
we're gonna encode these. Oh, I'm in fish.
Of course, I am.
It's like I just try to make my
life harder every single day that I do
these sessions.
Sesh doesn't want that there.
It should be okay. No. Can't do equals.
You need to do
set global
best as equal to this.
Alright.
And then
we are gonna
I'm assuming this is supposed to gonna get
you a load straight into the cluster. So
yes. And no namespace.
What
is wrong?
Alright. So let's see. I'm starting to troubleshoot
my problem over here.
I should be able to fix oh, no.
Bash is not happy either. Alright. I'm gonna
have to work out how do this in
fish.
So
cat EOF EOF.
I mean, why does that not work in
fish? What have I got wrong? The variable
interpolation is wrong.
Well, I mean, I just write a YAML
file. I don't even need to use it
to it this way. No. I think the
problem is the space. Well, that shouldn't really
matter either.
Why am I so bad at this?
Because it's live. That's fine.
Alright. Vem,
yaml. Yaml.
So that's that's what we're doing today.
And
I will get the value myself.
I'm gonna be horrible and see echo
what was it called?
GCP.
We'll write it straight into yaml. Yaml. And,
again,
this project will be deleted momentarily.
So
not that I think anyone would be able
to see the whole file. And
oh, don't do that.
No. That's femme. Why am I?
And now I've lost the buffer.
Wonderful.
There we go.
Whoo.
Alright.
Let's apply the YAML dot YAML,
and it's not happy.
Resource name is empty.
It's not.
Hey. There's nothing wrong with that.
Resource name may not be empty.
Gordon in the chat saying,
why does it exist?
More context, please. I've been sorry. I've been
typing so fast that I'm not sure if
I've missed something there.
I wonder if this is Where do I
see the oh, why does it exist?
Could it be tabs?
No.
Oh, it's definitely spaces.
Data credentials.
I must be tripping. That looks fine to
me.
No, it's a different error.
Unknown failed credentials.
Well, mean, it's just data. I've gone into
a secret. API v one, kind of secret,
metadata,
blah blah blah data.
That hanging tape is annoying, so let's just
drop that here.
Could that
I mean, it's just one lane. Right? Yeah.
Because it was stripped down. That's
component.
Ah, okay. I think it was just the
indentation.
What's that? I think it's just been the
indentation. And even though I think I'm deleting
spaces, I don't think I am. Yeah. It's
making me go through all of these. There's
just something in the docs that's
made that a bit weird.
So I'm assuming
To get under that too.
Yeah. I have no idea what I copied.
Maybe I should have paid more attention or
turned on my blank white space thingy in
BIM, but we got it applied.
I'm sure that was excruciating for people to
watch. I'm sorry.
But let's crack on.
I'm I'm I'm actually having fun. I'm like,
I've actually got a real smile on my
face. This is this is good fun.
Alright. So now that we've got a secret
created in our cluster, which is for the
CAPI GCP provider to do the things that
it has to do, We can now say
that we want to create a credential
within the system,
which just tells it that this provider secret
exists and it's got enough annotations here to
say this is how you access it.
Exactly.
I'm so sorry for my name and people.
That is horrendous.
YAML two has now been applied to my
cluster.
And that didn't have the weird spacing issue.
So we're good.
Now we've got a config map. This config
map
has go templates. I feel sad inside, but
I'll get over it. Yeah.
So this is is templates
that's setting up some secrets for the providers.
Okay.
I'm just gonna trust it.
And I should just have put all of
this into
one YAML with document separators,
but now I'm going for YAML three. So
config map.
Go.
Oh, that was the.
This is why you don't use terrible naming.
Okay. So now I can list regions. I
know I'm gonna go for Europe West 2.
I'm gonna need a network.
Well, it's a new project, so let's see
what we've got.
I've got mine configured for my old
my my production one. So
I just call it cordant, I think.
Alright. Cordant is a harmony chord because you
get harmony,
and arthro dent. That's where cordant comes from.
Alright.
Yeah. I never thought about that aspect of
it. But now that I've created a new
project, I've got a project, but none of
the API is disabled. However, I should have
been able to enable that.
Yeah. Permission to that.
Right. Oh, yeah. Okay.
Alright. Let's just do it from here.
APIs.
This rate monitor now is
frozen. And this is gonna go one of
two ways because Linux sucks on the desktop.
Because I'm gonna turn the monitor off and
back on, and it's gonna freeze this one.
Hey, Motel.
Well Yeah.
I'm gonna
I
should just buy a Mac, but I can't
do it. Alright. No. I don't
I can't.
It was one of my
the only sticking point I had.
Right.
I love that you can hear me, but
no.
Oh. I'm still here. I'm still here. Yeah.
I thought my computer had just frozen, but
I'm back. And the other monitor works again.
Such is life. But I'm glad that wasn't
me having to reboot my machine to rejoin
the stream.
Alright. So APIs and services.
And
I should all just turn them on.
No. Was compute.
Because this isn't a JKE cluster, we're not
gonna need the containers API or anything like
that. So I wonder how far we can
actually get with just the compute API itself.
I I probably assume that's maybe all of
it. There may be, like, the secrets API.
I'm not sure if you're using KMS or
secrets manager behind the scenes, but I'm gonna
assume not.
No.
Just because there's that as obviously, the KSM
as well, which will handle some of this
Alright.
Let's try this again for list networks.
Yes. It is.
I need to put the ID then. Because
there's already a card and project. So I'm
actually that's why it was a permission denied.
I'm trying to modify someone else's card and
project.
Oh.
Alright. Enable the CLI. I'll just pull it
till it's ready. So
Alright.
So that worked. We've got the default network.
I'm happy to use the default network.
And
we can list machine types by region. We
can just use an end to
end standard four.
We already listed the templates.
So now we get to the fun bit,
which is creating our cluster deployment.
So
where is this code?
So now
I
am
gonna name things a little bit nicer
so that we can follow along.
So we'll call this Rawkode production.
In this namespace, we'll go with the GCP
standalone.
I guess I should list it again to
make sure these versions haven't changed. So let's
just
Let's see. I don't think they should I
don't yeah. Go ahead.
There's a provider template.
There we go.
And
the other one was was it cluster templates?
Yeah. Cluster there's a cluster template and a
service template.
Alright. Okay. So the GCP standalone
is zero two one, same as the docs.
That's fine. I haven't changed the credential name,
so that should be okay.
We do need to paste in my project
name,
which is no longer in my history.
Grab that one more time. Should've called it
Rawkode Cordon just to make it easier.
You're Europe West 2.
Default network.
Oh, and I need the full name for
the image hardware list. So we will run
that command then.
Here.
List.
Oh, there's lots.
Ubuntu
20 o four seems to be what the
docs suggest using. How permissive
or restrictive as my Ubuntu version?
You still with me? Oh, yeah. I'm
I'm watching along. No. I was I was
thinking about
choice of operating systems when you run
your Kubernetes clusters. I'm I'm curious
what your views are around
does it really matter?
Would you care if someone gave you
a choice or no you know, what is
the
I think I know what this I know
I know the answer. It's gonna be you're
always gonna want a choice.
I mean, I know the best practice is
I shouldn't care. The clusters are supposed to
be as ephemeral as possible. I should have
lots of them be able to rotate them
back up, restore.
Yep.
In reality, I think so many companies
are so far away from that. I mean,
even in my production, which is not that
huge,
sometimes you just need convenience and debug ability.
Like, you know, I haven't adopted,
you know, immutable.
I haven't got in my production clusters,
etcetera. I mean, I just run that on
a desktop. So I always make compromises trying
to protect the tomorrow's problems.
Yeah. So,
yeah, I'm not that opinionated,
but I do need that break glass button
for when I need to get into and
do stuff. So Just get it done. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. So what are the yeah. I
mean, we're we're sort of thinking about how
how minimal could you make an OS. Right?
And could you then use something like
Distroless
to provide
your user space? And
what does that look like? And,
ultimately,
do people care enough to actually have something
like that important? I don't know the answer.
Wrong namespace.
There we go.
Alright. So cluster's not ready. Expected. Services zero
zero. Template correct.
Infrastructure ready. Wow. I wonder. Do we have
some compute nodes then?
Let's see. That'd be stupid.
That's a lot faster to enable. Yes. That's
for sure.
Oh, cloud storage. No. Other one.
Compute engine.
Yeah. I mean,
I don't want to just show me the
thing.
And so it's like the UI is caught
up with the fact that that is turned
on.
No. Alright.
Is there a refresh button?
Total VMs is zero. I'm assuming it's maybe
hopefully working on it.
Yeah. I think it's working on it. It's
probably it looks like you're
you need to make your screen bigger.
Alright.
Alright. Yeah. No instances yet.
I guess while while that's happening, a couple
of things that
should be interesting for
for people.
We are, of course, going to be offering
kubect,
so that that's being actively worked on as
well. So it'll just be another provider
with kubect.
And then,
we'll also want to, introduce
cloud hypervisor as well, so so people of
choice.
Taking a long time to list the machine
types.
Refresh. They always move this refresh button. I'm
like, just stick it in one place on
every screen, please. Sometimes it's over here.
My biggest concern oh, okay. It's just slow.
My biggest concern was maybe I picked a
machine type that wasn't available in the region.
I did n two. I do see n
fours.
So let's
and grep
west
two, but I also want to look for
standard dashboards.
I can always update this, I'm sure. So
I don't know why that I mean, I'm
sure it's fetching a decent amount of information,
but
not that much.
I'm pretty sure I could also just pass
dash dash region, which would probably restrict the
amount of data that I need to fetch.
But
the docs told me to use grep, so
I greped.
This is this is the reason why I'm
a fan of SSH. Right? You know, just
a little little faster on your
providers doesn't really help. So let's see. And
I'm in there. We we do have n
two standards.
So
there we go. Look at that. We got
a machine. Alright.
So let's
talk about what's actually happening
behind the scenes here. Right? So Yep.
We wrote a very small bit of YAML
that just says we want a cluster
with this name.
We picked a template from the list of
templates. I provided the credentials
with some small amount of configuration, the project,
the region, the network, and then the device
types to use across the control plane and
the worker plane. Yep. Now I know this
is just in behind the scenes. Mhmm. Which
means
what's happening here is on the kind cluster
I have locally,
it is generating all of the secrets for
the control plane to successfully join with each
other,
constructing the user data, dropping that into
Google's compute engine, and then the boxes come
online and
work.
Yes. So in theory,
this is just one big massive user data
script, assuming it doesn't change anything that Capi
is doing already. So
Yeah. We very much follow I mean, we
I think once you've been burned by
not doing something completely open source or diverging,
you tend never to do it again. Right?
And
I think we've got enough experience.
And what what's nice about this? Again, let's
focus on the abstractions that you and your
team I don't know how many people are
working on this. Right? I'll assume there's a
team of people. Yes. When you oh, there's
a lot. There's a lot of in
here. It's like if we focus on the
problem domain and why I mean, CAPI is
amazing,
but it is laborious to actually get a
cluster at the other end of especially when
you think about you have to configure that
the CAPI doesn't do the CNI for a
start. You that's the first thing you deploy
to the cluster. Yep. But I'm assuming if
I just pop in here as well as
handling all the certs and stuff is that
if we scroll down, we're going to see
or maybe it's not in the user's area,
maybe it happens in the control plane after
because there is a copy concept for doing
an apply after the control plane component.
But I'm assuming the CNI stuff is maybe
in there. So we can just see this
as just user data. Like
Yeah.
Alright. No.
So it's using k zeros for all of
the nodes and stuff like that. Alright. So
let's just get the cluster, which means it's
handing off to something else,
which I guess is a KSM,
potentially.
That is the KSM.
So this is yeah. And so, you know,
it's template based.
Now we can actually go and you know,
we've got this cluster, so now we can
actually
look at what nodes look like and then
actually deploy some beachhead services.
Okay. So one thing I did notice is
that I didn't see how many control plane
nodes I
want. Is this part of this GCP standalone
template?
It is. Obviously, you can go in and
and change it, or you can just add
that to the YAML file and define it.
Right?
Alright. So if I say, get me cluster
templates,
I say GCP standalone
and just grab this as YAML,
We we can see here.
I should've I don't how do you have
I done it on back?
Yeah. Let's raise it to fail. Dash or
YAML. Just so I can get colors. I
like colors.
Oh, again terrible naming.
Alright.
So where's the fun stuff? So we've got
a control plane configuration. So this is all
just vanilla cube admin config,
configure insider box, labels, network tags,
control plane number. So
I could just put in control plane number
under the right key and be able to
say I just want a single control plane
node, and that would just be overwritten or
merged together at the application
time.
And in fact, we can already see the
project and region are here too. So Yeah.
We're already doing some of that.
I don't know what the what the word
is, making some of those things explicit without
defaulting.
Is there a default operating system in here?
No.
There well, I mean,
I think the default would just be Ubuntu
right now.
But if you
if you go further down again
Oh, sorry. Yeah.
Yep. Just keep on going.
See the worker
the workers workers number is two right there.
Oh, yeah. +1 95.
Yeah. Yeah. Got it. So
Alright.
And that's that's what you can, you know,
you can change.
Anything that's in
the YAML files
that you would have to laboriously all edit,
you can put back in here.
Right. So if there are specialized things that
you want to do, you can.
Have you experimented
or plan on providing support for, like, queue
to make some of this, like, you know,
defined with a schema and and get autocomplete
and IDs and stuff like that. I know
that nobody's really using Q, but I'm always
trying to promote people to use Q because
I think it's such a great tool. Well,
I I I came from Weaveworks, and, you
know, everyone there was a massive fan of
it.
It's quite popular here at Marantus.
We
are talking about how do
make this even simpler,
and Q would be a way to be
able to do that.
The
once we
we've talked about, you know, KSM,
KCM,
and coordinate observability,
the the next piece
that we're gonna start developing is the
policy manager, so KPM,
and that will really
need something like Q to be able to
do it well.
Alright.
Now I'm looking at the time.
We can wait for this cluster to come
up and carry on. However, I think this
was a good amount of chunky work that
maybe if you have something else, we could
take a look at to see the two
additional components, the service layer and the observability
layer.
It would just save us. Because, I mean,
this could take twenty to thirty minutes. Yeah.
So
I'm trying to see what I can do.
How much time do we have?
So
it's in for another fifteen minutes, but if
we go over, it's not a big deal.
We do actually have three control plane nodes
online and two worker nodes, but they're not,
know, that's not finished the bootstrap process yet.
So maybe it won't be long as I
thought.
Yeah. Because
I would like to I would like to
just in the environment, be able to
show NGINX
and actually cover a
a portion of KSM.
Okay.
So maybe
where did you stop? Okay.
So I think what we'd want to do
is be able to look at the KSM
on on your
on your cluster.
Alright.
Well, my cluster state is
flapping between unknown and false. I think the
control plane machines are ready based on this
logline.
Yeah. So we might just be
waiting
on
the worker notes.
I'm assuming
and the secrets on the management cluster. So
this is my local
kind cluster.
In fact, I can see it already. In
the KCM system, we have a KubeConfig for
the Rawkode production
cluster.
Yeah. So I can probably just do QC.
Production.
We want the cube config.
Because you're gonna
Yeah. You're gonna control all of this on
that on that mothership. Now if the mothership
does go we call it mothership, right,
to Shikers Guide to the Galaxy.
If the controller
if if that mothership does go down,
you you will con you know, all of
the child clusters will continue to work. Right?
And that's why we have Valero, and we
have different ways of recovering.
So
it's it's one of the advantages we have
that, you know, you're able to
do real you can rebuild your mothership
and not impact or affect it.
Alright. So where are you?
Alright. So in the service template,
which one are you in right now?
Engine
you have the engine, Nick. What are you
doing?
So pulling out the secret, getting it to
JSON, hopefully, writing the value file, decoding it,
and putting it into a config file. Otherwise,
I realize it now says I don't have
JQ.
So I need to modify one thing before
I run that, which is just to add
JQ here.
And then in my terminal here, just reload
so that JQ pops in the environment.
It should be quick. I do use JQ
often.
Alright.
Succeeded.
Oh, okay. It didn't pop in the shell,
but, I mean, it did when I refreshed
it. Okay. So
get not found. Get see oh, I've got
two. That's why.
No. I'll iterate over null. Okay. So I
was a bit too galsh with my j
q. We do have oh, we don't have
items.
What did I see here?
Items.
Oh, I'm not getting anything back.
Oh, there there we go. So,
oh, it's just alright. Okay.
J q dot data dot value.
Base 64
dash d rate to q config.
Oh, come on. Be nice to me. Oh,
so this is just a gq thing where
it's quoted.
Nice.
And then export
kube config equals
kube config.
So now if I run get pods, this
should be the workload cluster.
We've got Calico, CoreDNS,
the CSI stuff for Google Cloud, controller managers,
proxies, metrics there. That is
a working cluster. Yeah.
And, you know, if you want, you can
look at the
you can look at the service templates.
Alright. The kubectl get
I'll do that from other shell, but I
don't speak into the management plan.
Okay.
I don't have any.
I'll go on and and on this
where are you now? Where'd you go? Oh,
sorry. I'm I'm I'm I'm trying to debug
one problem, and you're trying to help me.
I'll slow down.
I just wanted to make sure I was
still speaking to them at the local kind
cluster, which I am. So we don't have
service templates, but maybe I've made a mistake.
Yeah. So, I mean, if you if you
look at, like, the KCM, like, KCM dash
Valero,
it's running. So on the child cluster,
try the same thing again. Do the deep
Kube CTL,
get service templates, crash n,
and then, you know,
the namespace, which you called it. Which is
true. Oh, yeah. Now that
No service templates.
Of course.
I'm doing it over here.
So we do have service template type on
the management cluster.
Yeah. Do we need to deploy the service
templates,
or
are those done for us?
No. We're not we we're we we have
to
deploy it.
Let me see if there's no. There should
be one or two that are ready. It
the reason why I don't know the answer
right now is we're changing the code right
now.
And so I have to make sure.
Alright. So should I just copy this NGINX
Ingress example then and apply that to my
management cluster? I think it's a management cluster.
Right?
Yes. Alright. Okay. So service
templates dot YAML.
This is defining
just I mean, it's just an ingress one.
I'm gonna leave the namespace off. I'll do
that on Kube control.
And this service template just says we want
to deploy a helm chart
with version interval. First, it's just gonna how
often to sync it with
flux, fail those Argo. Yeah. This looks like
a flux a flux one.
Yep.
Which means, I guess, that I could also
do values and then
go nuts.
You can go nuts. I mean, you can
do, like, your resources. You can do things
to, you know,
set memory, set CPU. You you could do
all of that. Yeah. I just wanna pick
one value that exists. So then, you know,
I always like to break stuff. So
Well, controller up to two.
Where's the values fail?
Oh, this isn't the helm chart. Is that
in hack?
No. Okay. This is just not the helm
chart. Alright.
Oh, it was under charts. There we go.
So let's pick one value.
There we go.
Wow.
Okay. This is the helm this is why
I don't like helm. Every single lane gets
templated and
controllable.
I'm just like, why?
So
I I can't remember. Should this
be dot notation, or should I be doing
nested YAML?
Nested YAML. Nested YAML. Yeah. Okay. So we'll
say Rawkode is
here for my label.
Let's see what happens.
Apply this. That goes to values.
Oh,
alright. I made an assumption. So I'm gonna
do a kubectl explain
service
shorthand,
which was
s e c t m p l
spec helm.
Oh, I put it under chart specs. That's
gonna be the maybe that's the the problem.
Value files.
Okay. So I can't do values. I have
to do value files.
Relative path of the sorcerer. Alright. Let's come
back to that. Let's not break the demo
because I was curious.
Let's just get it applied.
That's me.
Told you I need to break stuff. Yeah.
It's fun.
There we go. Alright. So we have a
service template. Now the thing I don't know,
and maybe I should go to the docs
or maybe you could tell me, is now
that our management layer has the concept of
this
project and grows NGINX service template, how would
I tell it to roll this out to
my cluster,
or does it do it automatically?
It it
depends on how you wanna set it up.
It's all around,
credentials that you would hand to people. So
you can,
as the,
you know, super, super, super user
decide to apply this at the cluster level
at the at the mother ship level, which
means you could just do it now.
Or what you can do is you could
make it available
to the DevOps engineer,
the development engineer, so they can apply it.
It's up to you. So let's assuming I'm
the platform engineer here, and I am saying
every cluster must have NGINX. So how do
I do this at the mothership level?
Wait. Let me I'm just going in my
bash history right now.
You're asking me a question that
I should know off the top of my
head.
In the docs, I found a YAML interface
for a multicluster service, which takes a cluster
selector and a service spec, but I don't
know if if that So you could do,
like, a
well,
did you do the you did the kubectl
apply.
Yeah. I believe we we have a we
have a service template now.
Yeah.
Okay.
So
then I mean, kubectl apply
dash f,
the name of the thing.
I should call it out globally. Right?
I don't know. It does currently say invalid.
Describe service template. I don't know why that's
not all open for me.
Wait. Does describe work as a no. It
doesn't.
Alright. I made a mistake. It's failing to
download from the card and catalog.
I'm going there.
Was that something I can browse the Cortana
catalog? Browse it. So if you go to
GitHub
forward slash cordon.
Alright. Let's see if it finds it like
that. Catalog? Yep. Yep.
I could have picked anything. Wow. There's lots
in here. Okay.
NGINX.
Charts.
What version did I use? 4113.
Yeah. It's there. No. 4113 is there.
Yeah.
Alright.
Oh, there's a web version too. Nice. Okay.
Trying to see what
could have possibly So you're gonna deploy
the template with Helm as well. Yeah.
And then we deploy a multi cluster service.
Okay. Yeah. And you can do, like, what
I've done because I just wanted to make
it easy. I wrapped it around the shell
script
to do it. Right?
So I actually had to look at my
shell script right now.
Oh, that came back false too.
The
Is the catalog down? Is it broken?
Shouldn't be.
Try,
you try
what does it say? Oh, no. It's valid
now. Okay.
Alright.
This worked.
Maybe it's just taking too long. No?
I don't know. But I'm I'm gonna go
I'm just gonna YOLO that's more of a
cluster service then and then
let's see what happens. Again, having fun. So
just going through it. But
So when I Sorry. I'm
gonna say just touching
on
the because I said I'd say vibe coding
one time. If you think about
well, why not?
If you think about
what you've done now with
creating
templates for
KCM, KSM,
the observability
as well,
you have
a
platform
that is
a lot easier for models
to learn and then actually
be able to do things with it. Right?
So that's one of the sort of the
powerful things.
We had one of the sales engineers who
was frustrated because we don't have a UI
for it yet because we're using the Kubernetes
UI,
who
created a UI
in half a day. I told it what
I wanted to do and then and then
built it.
So that's sort of the nice thing about
this where you can, you know, abstract to
the level of being able to
pick,
different things, different providers, different types of services,
and actually have a model understand it quite
easily.
I'm not saying you should do that in
production environments,
but it opens up the idea of
this is easier to comprehend
than
tripping up inside of you know, for the
rest of this, tripping up inside of or
something else.
Yeah. Definitely. I
definitely vibe good a lot, especially, you know,
ever since MCP got a lot of adoption,
and there's MCP servers for for GitHub, for
GitLab,
for Kubernetes projects, for web APIs, for anything.
Like, you just end up
the whole agentic thing just does so much
for you now. The things that would have
taken me weeks to build you're doing in
a day is just amazing. It is amazing.
We we're we're trying to determine which of
the MCP servers we're going to
build on top of. What we don't wanna
do is replicate. So the Chordant MCP
will
leverage one of the I think the the
K 0 8 you know, there's the MCP
Kubernetes server, and then there's also MCP
k zero
eight.
And I think that's the one we're using
more than likely. So we'll have this here.
Okay. So
while we were chatting there, I very quickly
did one thing,
which was I noticed in the multi service
cluster wanted some sort of label selector
in the cluster. Now I could have defaulted
that and assumed I assume it would do
all, but I didn't wanna make any assumptions.
So I modified our cluster deployment to add
the owner Rawkode label.
And then
Mhmm. And then updated our multicluster
service with match labels owner of Rawkode. So
this should,
I believe, just deploy the thing that I
want. Okay.
Did you update the version?
The version of what? Sorry. The version numb
it
go back into the yeah. Go back in
there.
I don't see a version. Maybe I'll just
describe it again. It's in the it'd be
in the cluster template.
I have not modified the cluster template. Okay.
Just okay. Alright. I modified the cluster deployment.
It does
does have my label.
Yeah.
I mean,
it can yell at me.
Let's see what I've just done.
Alright. I'll just scrape it.
Ingress.
Yeah. It's doing it. There we go. Well,
it's also now applying
provisioning
our Helm chart on the target cluster.
So when I ran that cluster deployment wide,
it does say services zero zero. So
that looks like it's released.
Still getting zero there. However, if I pop
over to my other cluster,
to the workload cluster.
Let's see. We do have an
NGINX running. So I mean, that that's pretty
sweet.
Very cool.
And we're now an hour over an hour
and a half in, and we haven't even
touched on the observability stuff. Like, I mean,
there's just so much for us to cover
on this project.
I mean, we'd you know, happy to come
back, and and I can I can drive
a little bit so you so you can
kick back and relax? But it was a
lot of fun
seeing you dive in and getting this
up and running super quickly.
Right?
So
yeah.
Alright. Let me pop us back over to
Facebook.
So we covered a lot. Important project is
integrates with the whole ecosystem
and the cloud providers to give you a
Kubernetes cluster. It allows you to define
cluster templates, cluster deployments, service templates, multicluster services,
web cluster selectors.
And now it's just scratching what I feel
is part of project. It's been just on
what you've talked about and the documentation.
So
we know there's an observability bit built in
with OpenCost as well for FinOps,
but this is also a very young open
source project.
Mhmm. I mean, there's a road map. I'm
assuming you've got a thousand ideas or maybe
more.
Can you just give us an idea about
the status of the project right now and
where you plan to take it over the
next three, six, or nine months there?
Yeah.
Yeah. You know, we are
putting more
effort into Coordinate. So we're we're adding more,
you know,
developer engineering.
One of the big things we're doing right
now
is trying to promote this as an open
source project as well because
Cordant shouldn't be
a momentous
thing. It should be something that, you know,
the community leverages and and does.
Meanwhile, road map. I sort of talked
through some of them.
KubeVirt,
cloud hypervisor for us are very, very important.
We think that you should be able to
treat those just like any other node.
So that that'll be coming out very, very
soon.
I did touch on the coordinate policy management,
same sort of thing where you want to
be able to abstract,
policy
and
use the right languages, the right policy tools
for things. Right? So it's not a converner
versus
OPA
gatekeeper.
It is some of your policy is one,
some of your policy is another.
We'll start with those two.
And then as
we build that out, then we'll look at
things like Cube Warden. So
that's a direction we're going in as well.
We're looking at how do we invest on
the networking side too.
If you start thinking about
having Cordon
able to,
you know, provision anywhere,
theoretically,
you can start looking at, well, I could
have
a cluster
manager a child cluster child
control plane on AWS,
but maybe I wanna spin the notes up
on Hertzner because they're super cheap today.
Right, and to be able to do some
of that. So we're trying to put that
together and figure out how do we do
this
so that it's seamless.
And, of course, we're going to be rolling
out a UI
in the next two or three months.
Doing that,
part of that is,
to not develop a UI
for the platform engineering teams but for their
internal customers
so that a development manager can go
and build,
you know, through through a UI, through UX,
able to build
another cluster for them to spin up for
a CID
CICD test of whatever the whatever it is
they're doing. And because of the credentials,
you can then provide
one group access to certain clusters or resources
and another group different ones.
And I think that's where it's gonna get
a lot of fun being able to show
how
you're enabling
different
teams inside of your
company to be able to or organization to
be able to do things independently.
Nice. Simplified it. Yep.
Yeah.
Alright. So I think we wrap with maybe
a question from my end. You ran through
Cordent. You spent, like, an hour with Cordent
documentation
and everything.
If you had a feedback and if you
had something to comment on Cordent's future or
what would you like to see
with Gordon? What would that be? Like, this
is a question to you.
Putting me on the spot, man. Come on.
I
think
I mean, it's it's it's just one of
those spaces where Kubernetes needs more tools like
this.
Kubernetes
does need to be easier. And, you know,
at KubeCon London, again,
a month ago ish, you know, I just
spent the first day running around with my
camera asking people how many Kubernetes clusters do
you have? And, you know, the majority of
them said one. And I said, because you
want one or because you can only really
run one. And a consensus, I still want
more than one cluster, but they can't be
gone in operational overhead to do that. Again,
a lot of people, their maturity of Kubernetes
is still relatively early.
So it's a big commitment to do that.
And and some of the challenges are networking
with multi cluster and routing and some of
the challenges are speed on.
Some of the challenges is just
policy across multiple clusters. And then there's the
whole
RBAC and who can access which cluster and
can they access names pages,
like multitenancies
and other big things. So all of this
is hard,
and what we need are projects that can
come along and say, okay. Look. You need
to be able to just describe your cluster
at once. You spin it up. It works.
It ships Valero. It handles the disaster recovery
aspect, and we start to remove a lot
of the toil of day two.
So
there's a lot of room for improvement, and
everyone is trying to do this today because
it's still so early.
Now that's not direct feedback, just that I
think you're on the right path and the
easier you can make this for teams to
go from one huge cluster. It doesn't even
need to be it could be four nodes.
Right? Either way, one cluster. One. Yeah. Help
people get to have maybe two or maybe
three. Just allow them to bring them in
as they need and and spend them back
down and move the workloads around and give
them that true
control over where things run, when they run,
and for whatever. Like, that is the future,
and it's how do we get there, and
it's tools like this. So
Thank you. That's good feedback.
Yeah. I don't know if it was feedback
or avoiding the question, but trying to
No. I think your answer I mean, that's
the that's the goal. Right? Is how do
we make take this complexity, make it simpler.
And
you know? I think, you know and and
templates are really important. I mean, I hate
that phrase. It's it's it's overused. Right? But
it is really relevant in a lot of
these projects. Is it we need to be
able to give people opinions on how to
do things. Everybody thinks the Kubernetes cluster is
bespoke and artisanal and handcrafted and all this
nonsense when really everyone just needs a CRI,
a network and implementation,
backups,
and observability.
Right? The ability to get metrics, logs, and
traces from all the workloads into a single
pane of glass. All of that stuff is
the same for everyone,
but the plumbing underneath it can be different
for everyone. GCP customers, it's the same. AWS
customers, same hybrid architectures,
multi cloud, all of this. And, like, as
this matures and these tools, like and there's
a couple of tools in this space. Right?
But as they all
work together,
have standards,
compete, progress,
like the standard dev tech
cycle of a project, This gets better for
the end user, and I think that is
really exciting. So, you know, keep up the
great work. Keep pushing us forward and trying
to make people's lives easier. I think that's
a very noble mission, and you're off to
a great start. So Well,
and we wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for all the hard work in
CAPI or or
any of these other projects that we're, you
know, taking advantage of. So yeah.
Yeah.
As we say, you know, open source stands
on the shoulders of other open source giants.
So it's all built on top of Linux.
It's all built on top of c groups.
It's then built on top of OCI now.
And, yeah, let's just keep innovating and pushing
things forward. That's all we can do. Alright.
I'm lower than we expected, but I had
a whole lot of fun. I really wanna
say thank you for joining me, for taking
time out of your days to set and
you know?
This is the most hands on I've been
in a while. I was set for building
my own stuff, so it was a that
was pure joy for me all the way
through. And I'll give you a moment to
say any last words for the audience before
we we we close this up?
Maybe I would just like project. Right? Yep.
Go ahead.
Yeah. Just like to share that. Take a
look at the project, and we wanted to
be on the Kubernetes Slack, but that's, like,
completely stacked. So
the cordon channel is on the CNCF Slack
for now
because that's where we found the space. So
that's still up to discussion whether the project
gets donated or not, and we'll see where
things go. But, yeah, the project is developing.
We are hoping for
more new releases, more contributions.
So feel free to join the Cordon channel
on the CNCS Slack, and, yeah, put in
your feedback, your issues,
or or anything you have as a community
comment on this episode itself,
the Rawkode Academy channel, and, yeah, keep supporting
David's work as well. He's been doing a
phenomenal job.
Alright.
Awesome. I am gonna push the button to
move us to the goodbye tune. I hope
you all enjoy. I'm gonna go delete a
service account before any of your roguelikes get
onto that, and that we'll see you all
next time. Thank you so much. Have a
great day. Bye.
Demo's done, the code is shown, seeds are
corded, knowledge shown from Arendtas,
clear and bright.
Martin Stalla
shared the line.
Looking
good.
Rawkode
love this Monday stream.
Live the cloud native dream.
Check the links, join the chat inside.
Nowhere for questions
left to
hide.